وجه الحياه في مدينه حارم تبدل بعد
الزلزال
بالكاد يتعرف ابو علي على ملامح الحي الذي
يسكن فيه فاصوات الجيران وذكرياته معهم
اختفت تحت الركام
ابعد ابو علي عائلته عن البيت
في البيت اشياء بسيطه لها قيمه رمزيه عند
العائله وقد اشترت البيت بعد ادخار سنوات
واستغرق تجهيزه مده طويله هذا البيت كان
ستر غطاءنا وانما في حياتنا وعمرنا كله
وسبحان الله قدر الله ما شاء فعل
البيت كله
الاغراض لنشوف بدنا نروح دورنا على محل
نتاوى فيه وما استطاع ولا ادري ان يصلحه
نزح كثير من سكان المدينه خوفا من تجدد
الهزات الارضيه وفي السوق وجه اخر من
المعاناه
فمتجر ابو احمد مني بخسائر كبيره يصعب
عليه اتخاذ قرار بترميمه بسبب عدم استقرار
الاوضاع
بضاعه
شلت الضرر ما درجه في البيت بالبيت معروفه
يعني بالبيت
لبين ما الله يفرج علينا نعمر الكم ونفتح
رب العالمين
بخلي عدد من المحال التجاريه وبقي اصحابها
دون عمل
منذ الزلزال توقفت احوال السوق هنا فامام
احتمال ازاله الابنيه المتصدعه او ترميمها
يعيش السكان حاله انتظار مضنيه ريثما تفرغ
اللجان المختصه من فحص جميع الابنيه
المتضرره
تضررت البيوت حول المباني المدمره بشكل
بالغ
رافقنا لجنه من نقابه المهندسين اثناء فحص
عدد من البيوت
تحاول اللجنه الموازنه بين المعايير
العلميه وفقر حال اصحاب البيوت
وفي حال اتخاذ قرار بالهدم يحال الامر الى
اداره المنطقه التابعه للمعارضه مع نزيل
البناء للتكلفه العالي جدا لاعاده البناء
والوضع المادي بشكل عام وضع متدهور جدا
فحتى ما نزيد الناس تكاليف بيعات البناء
ينتظر اصحاب البيوت بلهفه نتائج الفحص
ومنهم من يتعجل سؤال اللجنه قبل وصولها
الى حيه
فالجميع يتخوفون من اي قرار بالازاله
تجدد الهزات الارتداديه يزيد من اضرار
البيوت المتصدعه ويرتبط ترميم البناء
باجراءات معقده وامام عدم وجود وعود من اي
جهه بتعويض المتضررين يقف السكان عاجزين
امام التكاليف الباهظه
وصل ابو علي مع عائلته الى مركز ايواء في
المدينه نفسها وقد فضل العيش في خيمه على
المجازفه بالعيش في منزل متصدع ووسط
المعاناه والمشقه يجد طريقه لاطفاء الفرح
والسرور على مشهد مغرق في السوداويه
خلت بيوت المدينه وامتلات ساحاتها بالخيام
ومع غياب حلول واضحه تستمر حاله الانتظار
صهيب الخلف الجزيره حارم ريفو ادلب